seaton mentioned Tom Curren this is
before the show cuz Seton you know loves
his Patriots he goes uh do you see the
tweet by Tom Curren and you know Tom
covers the Patriots and I said no I said
it's bad he goes I don't know I think
Curran might be hinting that this could
be the end of the line he covers the
Patriots for NBC Sports Boston Tom
Curren joins us now
were you hinting at something there
Thomas just observing just observing
because you know as he might have
related to you since you weren't
following a Twitter feed yesterday Dan
no that was to me I saw more unforced
errors by Brady I mean he had very good
throws mixed in most of them you know
the shorter variety but when he was
trying to go downfield to the perimeter
he was extremely inaccurate and you're
always going to get the great and
outstanding throws but there was a
higher ratio to me than I've ever seen
of just those weird-looking inaccurate
never had a chance type throws so I
don't think it's necessarily attached to
age to me there was some frozen that I
said it's something wrong with his
frigging hand because there were there
were some throws it just looked like
Jacoby Elsbury getting it in from Center
oh boy that's what you should have
tweeted out then I would have known that
this was a pakka lipstick this was the
end of the world for the Patriots here
how do you think this here's a Dion
Louis to is two days of you can play the
former Patriot running back Dion Louis
place for the Titans he had this to say
after the win over the Patriots here's a
verse we win you know especially we used
to be there and they want to bring you
back so definitely real sweet I'm happy
my teammates came out and played and I
love these guys
that's what happen when you go cheap you
get to ask him how's this plan I don't
know
I go cheap all the salmon if I get my
ass kicked I mean I'll just shop Oh God
I want to get one I'm there it's playing
interestingly in New England and I think
that we did a poor job because it was
pretty respectful all week of
appreciating just how motivated
different Titans people would be and it
wasn't just Dion Lewis because we look
at these guys and they all get paid they
all made their money but I still think
that there's that undercurrent of you
know you guys gave up on me that's why I
had to go get my money
brazen got traded to Kansas City that
sucked Dean tease the defensive
coordinator he is a rare coaching firing
Patriots fired him in 2009 he's been a
pain in their posterior since he was at
the Ravens he was a terrific terrific
games against the Patriots as a
defensive coordinator there and he had a
great plan yesterday all those guys I
think then we did a bad job of and
Malcolm bowler he just didn't factor in
as much as I thought he might have but
you know Dion Lewis on down the line and
if this happens to Lawson with this team
Dan you can go all the way back to 2003
with lawyer Milloy they went through 31
the nothing because the entire Bills
team drafted office his irritation the
2009 McDaniels game they beat the
Patriots out there in Denver 2010 there
was a weird Cleveland Browns win over
the Patriots a beat down in Cleveland
with day ball at Mangini and then there
was Patricia earlier this year okay but
is this team where would you stack up
this team at this point compared to last
year's team
they're not as they're not where same
same ish I mean all the things that we
looked at and said that might be a
problem
you know Trump needs solder go someplace
else Trent Brown comes in and there's no
no drop-off defensively Stephane kilm
was a hell of a lot better than he was
last year I think once they get this
what people have to remember is what
happened after every single one of those
these little bitterness balls what
happens the next week yeah every single
time they go on a tear and they did it
after Patricia this year they won six in
a row until they saw a variable right
well I think you know I look at Gronk I
think that's a bigger issue here because
I wonder you know what how much longer
is Grunk gonna play I don't think he's
gonna be back here next year I don't
think there's any way he'll be back here
next year whether or not he continues
playing someplace else remains to be
seen but he's got an eleven point seven
million dollar cap hit here this year
and they're not getting in any return
from him they wanted to get out from
under that before this year he folded
his arms and said I ain't going next
year it's 12 million and whatever
whatever he wants to do they'll put him
on a dolly and wheel them out of town if
they have to have you heard from Tom
Brady you know with your your tweets I
don't know does he respond to you does
he follow you cuz I know that yo you you
you're an apologist for Tom and I don't
want anything to come in between that
relationship I'm gonna be candid in if
you're gonna pick one guy to be an
apologist for it might as well be the
best appointment okay don't get
sensitive Tommy sensitivity thank you
Tom
Tom E Curran NBC Sports Boston for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
you